100
um you are it's crazy how long you've
been doing this and how
you're still in some some way i don't
know man i feel like
somehow you're still kind of underrated
when it comes to like the conversations
like these hip-hop conversations like um
do you feel like
is that kind of why you said that on the
last album like [ __ ] don't
deserve me because i feel like you don't
you you as much as you're like known for
your vice [ __ ] and your cooking [ __ ] and
all everything else like you're still
like
one of the the hardest dudes on the mic
and i feel like sometimes people thank
you man
people kind of overlook you in that in
that respect
now uh you know
i i can only do what i do you know
the show did take over in a crazy way
where people definitely know me a lot
from that and
you know you want to be able to you know
bring everything together to a head but
like i said i [ __ ] i've ushered in
this
the 2010s you know i've
ushered that [ __ ] and i'm here 2020
still headlining [ __ ] i'm you know
[ __ ]
this is this is like i'm trying to do
emmitt smith career you know
rap is like running back it's very
short-lived career you get hurt
bum knee get cut you don't have the same
performance as last year you have one
big
performance then the next year you're
down down on you they cut you
someone picks you up off waivers that's
what this rap [ __ ] is you're a [ __ ]
running back
i'm looking for the longevity you know
or when however long that i'm i'm
battling out my way
we're we will we will take you in
arizona if you would like to retire in
arizona that's what i'm saying i'll
[ __ ] you know emma smith
the career ends in arizona with the
record with the record with all-time
record
yup after a big 53-yard performance that
day
it was only 53 yards i don't it seemed
like you're right
25 carries 53 yards that's crazy to
think but i remember that
but he was a workhorse yes that's what i
am i'm a workhorse but you know like you
said man you know
it you're you you transcend
yourself through in rap it's been almost
you can consider it like light years at
this point with a decade
[ __ ] changes so rapidly and so quickly
to still
you know have a shot my fan base is
solidified and
i you know i always continue to you know
i'll be new to somebody today you know
someone just
find out about me today yeah it's crazy
to think i saw you said that uh
i was on there on twitter instagram that
your first album was 10 years ago
it really was it was you know 10 years
ago was the first project dr lecter came
out and
dr lecter and then well done right with
static yeah
yep yeah it's it's so crazy because it
makes me just feel old as [ __ ] because i
i still remember discovering i forget
which record it was when you were
rapping on the basketball court with the
knicks jersey on
you just experienced your experience